many people ask me questions about stoic
philosophy and practice I've created
this series to provide short answers to
the most common recurring or confusing
questions about stoicism so this is an
excellent question one that keeps coming
up time and time again does stoicism
believe in God and there's a lot of
clarification and even classification
that we have to do in order to
adequately answer this for those who
always demand simple and straightforward
answers in this case we can say yes
stoicism does believe in God and then we
have to add a but but it's not the God
that you have in mind when you're asking
the question unless you happen to be
thinking about the gods of ancient Greek
and Roman religion or what we're talking
about when we say the god of the
philosophers something we need to get
out of the way right at the beginning is
that the Stoics do not believe in a god
along the same lines that many believers
in the world religions that we encounter
today believe in God it's a different
concept so what are we talking about by
these world religions the Abrahamic
faiths we could talk about you know
Judaism Christianity Islam you know
various Indian religions as well whether
we're talking about Hinduism
particularly if we're talking about
devotional Hinduism you know even you
know theistic Buddhism because there are
theistic Buddhists and we could go on
and on
typically what goes along with that sort
of belief is that there's a God who is
in some way outside of the world we talk
about this as being transcendent to
creation or at least transcendent to the
the mundane or you know profane or
worldly realm and the Stoics don't
actually believe in that God is we you
know the opposite of transcendent is
imminent within
world and so the Stoics advocated
something like a sort of pantheism
rather than a transcendent theism so
that's one important difference another
really important difference is that when
you look at the world religions there
are some sorts of revelations that are
given and those are taken as normative
oftentimes these are codified into
religious texts you're not going to find
anything like that in stoicism
particularly in modern but even an
ancient stoicism you will find them
referencing the Oracles and some
interesting discussions about divination
but the Stoics were always rather
standoffish towards that they didn't
take that as providing an adequate basis
for figuring out the nature of the
universe or your life so they're not
theistic in the way that many of the
contemporary world religions are
theistic you might ask that well why did
you say the Stoics believe in God if
they don't believe in God the way that
many religious believers today
understand that that concept well
because they had a different concept and
this is what we typically call the God
of the Philosopher's as opposed to the
God of Abraham Isaac and Jacob that's
the way Pascal formulated it and the God
of the Philosopher's is one that we can
come to know primarily through reason we
don't need a religious revelation and
it's a God who's you know all good all
rational you know sort of a think of a
you know idealized and very powerful
version of human being although the
Stoics don't think that God is
all-powerful in some sense
Epictetus says you know somebody might
complain about God why did you give me
this body that has all these you know
screwy needs and messes with my mind and
this is the best stuff that God had to
work with you know make things out of
bodies this is what you get
so the Stoics have a very different
conception of God it is one that's not
only different from say Judaism
Christianity
Islam it's also one that was different
from the traditional Greek religion you
know a polytheistic kind of mishmash
which didn't have exactly you know any
sort of determinative codification
there's all sorts of different things
going on the stoic said all of that is
is really just superstitious nonsense at
best it can be allegorized to understand
the nature of God and the gods and we
can talk as well about God capital G
who's often just called Zeus and you
know God lowercase G similar to certain
conceptions of the angels and also
similar to the Neoplatonic conceptions
of these intermediary spirits dime onus
that that take part in ruling and
governing the universe and so you'll see
the Stoics talking about us living
within a Commonwealth of human beings
and and gods all of this is understood
as being in kind of a harmony so there's
there's there's nothing like you know
Aries seducing you know Hephaestus is
spouse artemis and then getting caught
by them the Stoics like Plato like many
others left that's that's just sort of
nonsense for the ordinary people so we
have a very important distinction here
not only is the stoic concept of God
different than that of traditional
theism it's also different of from that
of the polytheism of their time
everything that I've said up until this
point has been concerned with what we
call ancient stoicism as opposed to
modern stoicism the stoicism of today
which is in certain respects more
heterogeneous there's there's a wider
range of perspectives and there isn't
even complete agreement about what
modern stoicism itself is I'm linking
below to a symposium that we had about
that
last year that you can check out so when
it comes to modern stone
there are some who say that all this God
talk just forget about it
and there they're atheists they say that
was fine for ancient culture it was a
useful way of conceptualizing the
universe and the human beings placed in
it but we've moved beyond that so there
are atheist modern Stoics there are also
theistic modern Stoics interestingly
they come from a wide range of religious
perspectives some of them are Jewish
some of them are Buddhists some of them
are Christians you know some people want
to see connections between stoicism and
Taoism all of that is is you know
requires some syncretism I think in
order to make work because there are
some some places where ancient stoicism
and say Judaism or Christianity we're
clearly at odds with each other and
couldn't be in an entire agreement but
that said those are two ends of the
spectrum and then there are some people
in between who are more agnostic and say
I don't really need to worry that much
about all of this maybe we can
allegorize the Stoics already
allegorized
God talk and then there are a few people
some who you know view themselves as not
really modern Stoics and they have
different names for how they fit in some
of them were just the Stoics some
traditional stomachs who say that you
actually do have to accept the stoic
conception of God as Zeus as the logos
running through everything Providence
and so on down the line so there's a
very wide range of belief but what you
can say is that there are some people
within the modern stoic movement who do
in fact believe in God and ancient
stoicism very clearly did believe in God
but it's the stoic conception of God not
you know Christian Muslim devotional
Hindu or you know traditional
polytheistic conceptions of God
if you want to know more about this
topic of Stoicism and god I think the
best place for you to go is to Cicero's
dialogue on the nature of the Gods which
features three characters one
representing the epicurean school one
representing the stoic school and one
representing the academic skeptic school
who are dialoguing with each other and
setting out what their respective views
are in and criticizing those views that
is an excellent starting point I would
also read around in Senecas letters
Epictetus is discourses and marcus
aurelius as meditations those are
particularly helpful as well and that
will give you at least some conception
of what it is that the Stoics mean when
they use this term God if you found this
answer helpful for you then please share
it with others who might benefit from it
this work is entirely supported by
crowdfunding on my patreon site so if
you find it valuable consider becoming a
supporter at patreon.com slash Saddler